il faudra aussi que je vous emmène à
excalibur c'est des copains ah ouais
franchemen c'est gratos pour les filles
à plein de meuf un peu rose ya de quoi
vraiment se régaler gachot qui a des
loups garous la toile caméraman recul
parce que ça risque de chauffer recul
provocation lundi soir
attention sont bourrés de cette vie là
bas et on s'arrête pas à cette afrique
vous savez quoi c'est écrit c'est bon
les loups on veut pas de problème ah
ouais pardon pardon vous a peut-être
interrompu voies dédiées peut-être en
train de vous renifler le cubain alors
la star est tombée on se renifle aucune
uniquement quand on se connaît pas pour
vérifier l'auteur de l'anus de l'autre
c'est tout daniel arrête un film muet il
paraît qu'en fait les vampires cdp des
refoulés désolé je vous ai pas déconner
quoi on est des pros portait exactement
comme de véritables loups bas on a
arrêté d'insulter les gens nous a
insultés mais elle va chercher la
baballe
non il va pas dire que c'est un piège à
temps là au déjeuner c'est eux qui nous
insisté matt ça me fait super mal ses
nerfs veux pas qu'on se qualifier en
quarts mais j'hésite à prendre et voilà
via humain tu sais pas l'appeler russe
est bon merci les gars c'est très drôle
où vous êtes complètement inconscient
ivan pagniez